this is kind of interesting
we have a bunch of primaries today those
primaries today in pennsylvania there's
also primaries today in north carolina
in north carolina one of the people that
is up for um
election for re-election
is radical trumpist republican
congressman madison cawthorne now
because of madison cawthorne's habitual
law breaking and also i guess we would
call them off color comments about
washington d.c about orgies and cocaine
as you might remember he's now been
caught two or three times trying to
bring guns uh through tsa security he's
had a bunch of
police interactions involving speeding
and i don't remember if it went over to
reckless driving or not
the republican party leadership seems to
not be thrilled with madison cawthorne
and it's believed although it has not
been proven that it is the republican
party that is behind some of these uh
distasteful i guess we would call them
or videos or compromising videos i don't
even know what term to use
uh racy videos of madison cawthorne that
have been released the idea being that
the republican party establishment is
kind of sick of cowthorn and they want
him out well he's in his primary uh
fight and that primary is today and even
though he is still winning
uh donald trump
now
seems to have come out of the woodwork
posting on truth social truth essential
yeah he calls it truth central i call it
truth social donald trump sort of uh
trying to help madison cawthorne and
defending him posting quote at 18 years
of age madison cawthorne the now 26 year
old congressman from the great state of
north carolina
went through a life-changing event the
likes of which fortunately few people
will ever have to endure
in just seconds he lost the use of the
lower half of his body a traumatic
experience to say the least that that's
true he was in a car accident terrible
when madison was first elected to
congress he did a great job
recently he made some foolish mistakes
which i don't believe he'll make again
let's give madison a second chance so
there's a bunch of funny things about
this
the first layer of this is that look at
how long donald trump waited
to make this endorsement of madison
cawthorne why did trump wait so long he
wanted to make sure he wasn't endorsing
a loser
even though madison cawthorne has lost
significant support significant support
uh for the um
uh uh from the republican party and
within his primary
it is now pretty clear that he's going
to win the primary i would be shocked if
the polling is wrong he's still he's
ahead by less but he's still ahead i
would be shocked if he lost
trump is coming out with this the day
before the primary because trump is very
concerned with his record
and um we are now going to see
what the ultimate results are but trump
if trump doesn't particularly care about
kawhorn other than sure cawthron is a
supporter of trump trump just wants to
uh tack on wins onto his supposedly
great endorsement record which is
actually sort of mediocre that's number
one number two this is another reminder
that the norms of the republican party
trump genuinely doesn't care about them
and we sort of knew that madison
cawthorne talking about uh orgies and
cocaine and all these different things
trump genuinely doesn't care about that
and it reminds us of what early on in
the 2016 primary with the republican
party
created a rift between trump and other
republicans uh turns out that uh trump
will just support anybody that supports
him assuming it won't be hurtful to
trump or damaging to trump in some way
and that's exactly what we are seeing
here so we're going to follow all of
these results tonight in pennsylvania
we'll be streaming results live north
carolina will be streaming results live
i hope you'll join me we'll be live on
youtube twitch and facebook and we will
also have more on these stories on all
of our platforms including instagram
where you can find us at david pakman
show
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high-quality
vitamins and minerals and my probiotics
and it's all from whole food sources i
drink it in the morning i know i'm good
i don't have to be messing around with
different pills and supplements or
whatever or spend time planning when
what time of day do i need to take each
one i just get it all with one scoop you
can put it in a smoothie you can drink
it straight it tastes great and then i'm
just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below